let's say we have two intersecting lines
so that's one of the lines right over
there and then I have another line right
over here so those are my two
intersecting lines and let's say we know
that the measure of this angle right
over here is equal to 7x plus 182 and
this is being given in degree so it's 7x
plus 182 degrees and we know that the
measure of this angle right over here is
9x plus 194 degrees so my question to
you is what is the measure of each of
these angles and I encourage you to
pause the video and to think about it
well the thing that might jump out at
you is that these two things are
vertical angles they're the they're the
opposite angles when we have these
intersecting lines right over here and
vertical angles are equal to each other
so we know because these are vertical
angles that 9x plus 194 degrees must be
equal to must be equal to 7x plus 182
degrees and now we just have to solve
for X so if we want all the X terms on
the left hand side we could subtract 7x
from here we got to do it to both sides
of course in order to maintain the
equality and then we could put all of
our constant terms on the right hand
side so we can subtract 194 from the
left we have to subtract 194 from the
right in order to maintain the
inequality and on the left what we're
left with is just 2x and on the right
what we're left with let's see 182 minus
194 so it was 194 - 182 would be
positive 12 but now it's going to be
negative 12 we're subtracting the larger
from the smaller so it's equal to
negative 12 and then divide both sides
by 2 and we get X is equal to negative 6
and now we can use that information to
find out the measure of either one of
these angles which is the same as the
other one so we can see here that if we
take 7 7 times negative 6 plus 182 so 7
times negative 6 is negative 42
Plus 182 is going to be equal to 140
degrees and you'll see the same thing
over here if we say nine times negative
six which is negative 54 plus 194 this
also equals 140 degrees